hey 42 here the move from free G to 4G
was a small but impactful one it was
little more than a speed and reliability
boost
however it's enabled people for the
first time to stream HD video almost
anywhere play online games and what
YouTube on-the-go but 5g will shake
things up like never before because it's
not just an improvement on current
technology it's an entirely new beast
looking at the radio frequency spectrum
3G signals lie in the 1.6 to 1.9
gigahertz range 4G is around 2.5
gigahertz but 5g will operate between a
huge range of 1 to 86 gigahertz that's
huge
on top of this 5g will also broadcast in
an entirely new classification of radio
frequency that has never been used
before for mobile data millimeter wave
frequencies all this means there is a
boatload more energy being carried
through the airwaves at any one moment
and there could be some really
unsettling consequences of this I'll
talk about those in just a minute but
first if you're thinking isn't this
going to cost a shitload of money and
require a huge new infrastructure you'd
be correct the issue with millimeter
waves is they don't travel very far at
all each transmitter will have an
effective range of anywhere between a
few hundred meters to 1 kilometer unlike
what you may have heard 5g can penetrate
walls and windows is just not very good
at it and thick walls will significantly
dilutes the signal strength so in dense
urban areas to transmission range of a
single 5g antenna could be less than a
hundred meters far far less than current
4G
furthermore the 5g signal range will be
absolutely destroyed by rain the high
frequencies employed by 5g are easily
absorbed and thus halted by water and
yes in case you were wondering that
includes the water in the human body the
ingenious solution to 5gs lack of range
is more antenna a lot more luckily 5g
antennas can be far smaller than their
4G equivalent new backpacks
sighs boxes called small cells will be
placed roughly every 250 meters around
cities they will be a lamppost traffic
lights decided buildings there may be
one or more coming soon to your street
they act like relay station repeating a
signal from a much larger base tower
somewhere nearby these tiny boxes will
form a huge web that is sufficiently
large and dense but it can fill in any
blanks signal spots overcoming the issue
of poor 5-t range the antennas will also
employ a technology called beamforming
this essentially means that instead of
indiscriminately shooting out 5g signals
in all directions like 4G dos the
signals will be sent directly to your
device the web of small cell antennas
will triangulate your exact location at
all times so it knows precisely where to
shoot the beams they will even be able
to calculate how to bounce beams of
windows and other objects to reach you
the issue is that to do all it properly
thousands of small cells are needed
it's estimated that New York will
require over 10,000 small cell antenna
boxes to provide the entire metropolitan
area with reliable coverage you won't be
able to turn a corner without seeing one
of these things but there's an obvious
issue here won't this be tremendously
expensive yes won't rural areas and even
towns be left years behind the curve
because all this money in infrastructure
will be focused solely on large cities
absolutely it could be the same story as
4G all over again 4G in large cities is
mostly fantastic but there are built up
areas of the UK today that still have
piss-poor 4G coverage 10 years after its
introduction furthermore most countries
still haven't actually rolled out the
full potential of 4G even in cities such
as London in New York 4G can reach
speeds of up to 300 megabits per second
in lab conditions and a hundred megabits
per second in the real world but
according
to an open signal report the average
speed of 4g in America is just 16
megabits per second on the UK 23
megabits per second the countries with
the fastest speeds are South Korea
Singapore Norway and the Netherlands
which all have average speeds of over 40
megabits per second although things may
be different with 5g companies all over
the world seem to have a stick up their
respective rear ends to get 5g to
everyone everywhere AT&T says it will
have nationwide 5g coverage in the US by
2020 and Vodafone and EE in the UK have
already turned on 5g in some cities as
of May and 15 / UK towns and cities will
have coverage by the end of the year if
these mobile Giants are so keen to get
5g on the table faster than fish and
chips then there must be some serious
commercial benefits far more so than 4G
ever offered well yes there are they're
all getting their wires in a tangle over
5g because it will enable lots of
exciting new tech that they can sell to
consumers for a pretty penny the first
and most obvious is fast and mobile data
speeds standards authority such as free
GPP stipulates that for a network to
call itself 5g the base station has to
be able to support download speeds of 20
gigabits per second and uploads a 10
gigabits per second this equates to a
2.5 gigabytes per second download speed
o speeds you could download a full HD
movie every second this is hundreds of
times faster than everyone's home
broadband speeds unless for some strange
reason you pay an extortionate fee for
dedicated multi gigabit lines and you're
now using all that power to watch
YouTube now of course no one is actually
going to get 20 gigabits per second
download speed on 5g in the real world
not prove all those blasted walls and
people knocking around now and don't
forget the evil rain but early estimates
suggest that users could get anywhere
from a hundred megabits per second to
four gigabit per second real-world
download speeds straight to their mobile
device so there you go you can now
achieve your life one go
Bishan of filling your phone 64
gigabytes of storage of random HD movies
in about 2 minutes time this much
download power is actually rather
redundant it far exceeds what an average
user could fully utilize but the speed
isn't what makes 5g so world-changing
it's des latin c latin c is simply the
time in milliseconds it takes for two
devices to talk to each other average 4g
latency is 50 milliseconds so when you
type a web address into your phone and
press GO it takes 50 milliseconds for
that request to reach the nearest 4G
antenna and then another 50 milliseconds
for the data required to display that
webpage to return to your phone
5g latency however is less than one
millisecond even with modern break net
fiber home internet speeds we are used
to waiting for webpages to load anywhere
from 20 milliseconds to one second on
the strongest home broadband connections
but with a Latin si of 1 milliseconds or
less as soon as you press load on your
phone or laptop that webpage will appear
instantaneously there will be no delay
that is perceivable by the human visual
system so long as the web server on the
other end doesn't provide a bottleneck
and yes you will be able to replace your
home broadband service with 5g very soon
if you want to so you will regain a few
milliseconds of your day
so what well this may not seem like a
very impactful change but having a
global data network operating with a
non-existent latency opens up a realm of
technological and lifestyle altering
possibilities that the human race has
never experienced before one such
example is in the field of self-driving
cars we all known our self-driving cars
are just around the corner and semi
autonomous consumer vehicles are
available to buy today but the real
change will come when 5g enables
self-driving cars to talk to each other
and their surroundings imagine that your
self-driving car passes through a set of
traffic lights on green at a four-way
Junction then all of a sudden a reckless
perhaps
driver comes from the right-hand lane
totally ignores the red light and zooms
across the junction at high speeds at a
90-degree angle to you
normally this would result in you
smashing right into the side of that
idiot in questions car which could be
fatal but what if their car was 5g
enabled and could alert some kind of
cloud service that they are heading
towards the junction it's a ridiculous
speed and your 5g enabled self-driving
car can tap into that very same cloud
with no delay and predict the accident
happening before you even see the other
car approaching your car could
automatically slam on the brakes and
potentially prevent an accident that
could end your life furthermore the
traffic lights themselves would also be
5g enabled and knowing there's a
dangerous vehicle approaching they could
switch to red until the danger has
passed
none of this life-saving synchronization
could happen without the extremely low
latency offered by 5g if there was one
overwhelming benefit to 5g then it's
probably its potential to save many
thousands of lives each year by
preventing traffic collisions a cloud
service may not even be required its
forts that 5g enabled cars could talk
directly to each other and constantly
emit their speed and trajectory to all
of the cars around it almost as fast as
a speed of light making a collision
almost impossible they could also
communicate across entire cities
alerting drivers to upcoming traffic and
roadworks and if you do get stuck in
traffic then it will be a lot smoother
today traffic could flow significantly
faster if it weren't for those meatbags
behind the wheel who constantly speed up
slow down and change lanes every 30
seconds this or an organized chaos
causes everyone to reach their
destination slower 5g however will
enable cars who all travel at precisely
the same speed on a sort of unlinked
road train this means that everyone gets
out of the traffic
faster this road train will even be able
to synchronize its breaking across 5g so
that if the front car hits something
then a ten car pileup could be a thing
of the past
emergency services can also be instantly
alerted to the location and details of a
nearby accident and because 5g utilizes
beamforming bandwidth can be
automatically reserved for the emergency
service vehicles passing by the antenna
so nearby consumer data usage doesn't
prevents them from doing their job 5g
will also enable some neat new texts
such as Wireless VR with instant
response rates which will finally
prevent people from throwing up after
they use a VR headset and augmented
reality with absolutely no delay and
photorealistic graphics there are some
people however that say 5g could be the
most dangerous man-made fret to our
species in human history understandably
radiation is a huge concern for everyone
it can be an invisible killer in the
early 2000s the widespread adoption of
mobile phones bought the lung and a
heated debate over whether their
prolonged usage is going to give us all
brain cancer but since the white but
adoption of mobile phones there hasn't
been a noticeable increase in brain
tumor rates there has been a 34 percent
increase in reported brain tumors but
that's because our detection methods
have improved over the same period that
mobile phones became popular no study
has yet been able to find a strong link
between the RF waves emitted by phones
and increased cancer rates in 2011 the
World Health Organization declared that
RF fields are possibly carcinogenic but
they explicitly stated that this doesn't
mean they are it means that the results
from multiple studies are too
inconclusive to say for certain
the w-h-o has also placed coffee and
pickled vegetables into the exact same
category in reality it's unlikely that
waves emitted by current phones are
actually carcinogenic because they're
very weak and these weak signals don't
contain enough energy to damage you
DNA or cells the problem is that 5g
waves carry significantly more energy
than 4G almost as much as a microwave
oven
turning entire cities into constantly on
microwave ovens sure sounds dangerous to
me many people including some in the
science community have expressed their
concerns that the high frequency
high-energy 5g radio waves could
interfere with our DNA cause cancer and
could even be militarized because water
is excellent as absorbing 5g waves and
human skin is peppered with sweat plans
containing a lot of water some think
that during riots the police could turn
up 5g emissions in the area to hugely
increase the body heat of the rioters
this intense feeling of burning all over
the skin that it could cause could give
them no choice but to disperse from the
area all this sounds very dystopian but
what's the truth well we don't know yet
for every experts opinion in study that
says 5g is totally safe there is another
that says it might not be there are some
accusations that are likely just
fear-mongering for instance 5g could be
used to heat human bodies as a form of
crowd control extremely unlikely 5g
maybe close to microwaves on the
spectrum but that is totally ignoring
intensity microwave ovens concentrate a
huge amount of their energy within a
small confined space if the same
microwaves were emitted outside it would
have little effect on humans guess what
visible light is higher on the RF
spectrum the microwaves
yet we don't all cook like jacket
potatoes from the inside out every time
the Sun shines a little bit because
within the same area the photons of
visible light contain significantly less
energy than inside a microwave oven just
because they are a higher frequency
doesn't mean they have a higher energy
intensity and so too would 5 g wave
contain far less energy than would pose
a potential heating risk to the human
body
some scientists reports that the amount
of energy emitted by 5g would need to be
cranked up by over a
thousand times in intensity before it
could pose a threat or be used as a
weapon and in regards to causing cancer
well as far as our current knowledge of
radiation is concerned there should be
nothing to worry about
all RF waves are radiation which sounds
rather scary
but for RF waves to interfere with human
cells it has to be ionizing radiation
this is a type of very high-energy
radiation that carries sufficient energy
to detach electrons from atoms inside
your body
when ionizing radiation hits the human
body it disrupts the atoms and the
chemical bonds that hold our DNA
together with enough exposure this can
cause cancer and other issues such as
lowered fertility and birth defects the
upper end of the visible light spectrum
UV light is actually ionizing radiation
that's why we should all wear sunscreen
outside but 5g waves are non ionizing
they're not even remotely close to
carrying enough energy to disrupt our
atoms and DNA as far as we are aware the
worst thing that non ionizing radiation
can do to the human body is heat it up a
little bit and that's only a concern at
very high intensities as we've discussed
earlier literally thousands of studies
have been done on the effects of non
ionizing and ionizing radiation and yes
a few experiments with rats have thrown
out some odd and worrying results but
these are thwart by the thousands of
other studies that have overwhelmingly
come to the same conclusion that it
isn't possible for non ionizing
radiation to caused chromosomal or
cellular damage it simply doesn't have
the required energy it's easy to get
carried away when an odd study now and
then produces a disturbing result but
one should always exercise caution when
using such a result to outright ignore a
mountain of evidence to the contrary
after all scientific studies can be
deeply flawed in many ways on both sides
of the argument
all this means that if 5g does pose a
risk to human health it would have to be
through a mechanism that we are not
currently aware of something that truly
flies in the face of our current
time-tested scientific model of how
radiation works I'm not saying that it's
not possible it's just improbable but
the nature of science is to keep asking
questions and testing new theories after
all absence of evidence is not evidence
of absence
do I think we should really be testing
out the effects of 5g on human health
before a mass rollout yes absolutely
100% many in the scientific community
even those who have no current concern
over its safety think that it's
irresponsible to roll out this tech
without more time to thoroughly test its
real-world effects and consequences
unfortunately we're not going to get to
that luxury hundreds of billions have
been invested into 5g tech by mobile
companies in every major nation there
are huge profits to be made and massive
potential so 5g is coming whether you
like it or not only time will tell if we
all have two heads by the end of it
today's video is sponsored by Nord VPN
the only VPN to get a perfect score on
PC Mag they have thousands of superfast
servers in over 60 countries Nord VPN
uses military-grade encryption and has
absolutely no data logging it works on
any device Android iOS Windows Mac Linux
you name it seriously I even run this
finger my android TV to watch content
from around the world I travel a lot and
I often do sensitive work on my laptop
banking messaging private documents etc
in coffee shops hotel rooms and public
spaces I always use Nord VPN in these
instances no questions asked because
it's easy for hackers to intercept your
packets over public Wi-Fi and see
everything you're doing online Nord VPN
double encrypts your data so
you can use any Wi-Fi connection 4G or
5g and note that you're completely
protected and your data is secure click
my unique link in the video description
to get 75% off a free year plan and then
to the code for TB check out for an
extra month completely free thanks for
watching subscribe for a new video every
week and a big THANK YOU to the sponsor
Nord V p.m. don't forget to check them
out using the link below